okay so democrats absolutely lose it
because they don't believe
in the traditional vision of the courts
they don't believe in federalist 78
where alexander hamilton called the
supreme court
the uh the least dangerous branch where
he declared the judiciary has neither
forced nor will
and that if it were disposed to start
exercising its will
instead of simple judgment it would lose
its reason for being they just disagree
with alexander hamilton they think that
the court
should basically just be another
democratic super legislature
and so now they are very very very upset
and they are suggesting that this thing
is illegitimate illegitimate by
illegitimate what they actually mean is
we don't like it so nancy pelosi tweeted
out
president trump and senate republicans
have committed an act of supreme
desperation
jamming through a supreme court nominee
just eight days before election day as
part of their years-long campaign to
destroy americans health care
and first of all this is such a strange
reading amy coney barrett is not
striking down obamacare it's not a thing
that is going to happen
in fact she was on a moot court and she
didn't strike down obamacare
so democrats are immediately going to
results results-driven jurisprudence you
see what they're doing here
the idea is amy coney barrett is bad
because she's not giving democrats what
they want
and it's not that she's not going to
faithfully interpret the law it's that
if she faithfully interprets the law
they might not get what they want this
is why democrats are going nuts
today right democrats are going nuts
similarly speaking
over a uh a 5-3 vote along ideological
lines
last night there's a case called the
democratic national committee versus
wisconsin
state legislature the wisconsin state
democratic national committee
had been pushing to allow mail-in
ballots to be counted if they arrived as
much as six days after the polls closed
on election day a lower court had shot
down that plan
justice roberts joined the four
conservative justices in refusing to
overturn
their decision the lower court's ruling
will now stand the late ballots will not
be accepted so wisconsin cannot count
mail ballots that arrive
well after the polls close which makes
perfect sense because obviously it's
gonna be difficult to tell who is voting
after election day
and who is not democrats are very upset
about this
again they see this as a political move
according to ian millhiser who is one of
the idiots over at vox.com he says what
is surprising is two concurring opinions
by justices neil gorsuch and brett
kavanaugh
each of which takes him at one of the
most foundational principles of american
constitutional law
the rule that the supreme court of the
united states has the final word
on questions of federal law but the
highest court in each state has the
final word
on questions of state law this division
of power is implicit
in our very system of government so
they're saying the supreme court just
overruled the wisconsin supreme court
but um
that's ridiculous the supreme court lets
the states speak where the constitution
does not speak and
the constitution of the united states
certainly does not mandate that votes be
counted six days after the election
hey but again democrats get angry at the
court when they don't get what they want
from the court
not when the court violates the
constitution but when they don't get
what they want
senator kamal harris tweeted out
similarly to nancy pelosi we're not
going to forget this
we won't forget this says kamala harris
quote
today republicans denied the will of the
american people by confirming a supreme
court justice through an illegitimate
process okay it is perfectly legitimate
and by polling data amy coney bear was
popular a plurality if not an outright
majority of americans wanted to see or
confirmed
she says all in their efforts to gut the
affordable care act and strip healthcare
from millions with pre-existing
conditions
we won't forget this again this is just
myth-making there's nothing in amy coney
barrett's record that suggests that
she's about to overturn obamacare it's
just nonsense
it's just absolute nonsense but again
scare the living hell out of americans
to justify everything you're about to do
is the name of the game okay understand
that this is where this is going
in order to get what they want democrats
are now basically suggesting
that the other side is engaged in
radical evil and this now justifies what
we're about to do
if we pack the court well that was your
fault if we decide that we are going to
get rid of the senate filibuster all
together well that's your fault guys you
started it
you now again the irony of this argument
cannot be overstated democrats started
this with regard to judges
they did it was democrats who violated
every prevailing norm for generations
in order to get judges they want and to
reject justices they didn't like
but now their claim is that republicans
have violated the final war and
therefore all norms go away
good news all the norms are gone and
they can do everything they've wanted to
do for a very long time
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button